so because of a weakened immune system
they pull the tooth out this mucor is
opportunistic Boom it enters through a
tooth and you're saying it went to his
brain yeah so it went up through his
sinuses and everything cuz you know he
got all the blood vessels right there
all the nerves and all that and how long
does it take how long does it take to
travel to your brain is it hours is it
days once you get the infection I think
it's pretty quick so the first day they
got there once they kind of figured it
out they went and like went up through
his nose and surgically removed sinuses
like part of his sinuses like you know
these antifungals we have like we were
trying like the biggest ones and it just
wasn't doing anything cuz it had been so
bad it was so bad when he got to the
hospital and it actually went up into
his brain and they were talking about
having to go in I think they were trying
to they had to resect part of his brain
are you serious he lived through this no
no he
was no no most of these people did not
live